hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend and no
Sona was not just punching me before she
fled back to her chair you swatted her
elbow first yeah you did you scooted
over no I was trying to help her she
seemed unsteady I was helping her adjust
herself in her seat no oh oh okay I
didn't realize I think you're just angry
I was talking about how many cups you
had yeah it was a narc over here that's
right yeah get ready this guy's working
listen there was some Shenanigans just
before the podcast started maybe uh I
took a swing at sewn his shoulder yeah
slightly missed it and then she needed
to retaliate and then of course teacher
teacher I saw what happened I did see
what happened from Mr Matt gorley I did
and I tell the truth I appreciate it
you're a truth teller no one asked you
you my big
here are the three things that went
through my head RoboCop style like I had
a readout of options it was my big baby
my big daddy and my big gay boy
I'm none of those things you're none of
those things I'm not saying this is like
good or right or healthy
I have a problem I like that this
seconds ago I was taking a swing at Sona
and she was returning Fire by swatting
at me and then you end up the villain am
I the villain or am I just the
Misunderstood genius I appreciate it I'm
looking it up right now and no villain
and fool okay big giggy oh man you're
just the worst well it's it's faulty the
machine the wiring's off but someday
it'll get there uh I do love I used to
love when people would get really angry
and try to
yell at someone and swear but not be
able to pull it off yeah and I knew
people that would do that I know someone
in particular I won't name them but
they'd be like
[Music]
[Laughter]
fuckler and they just couldn't put
it together that's my that's me
how damn you
man
yeah it's just so easy to curse let's
see it go ahead Jesus piece of
dick you're just a big
sandpaper baby who's got little feet and
don't even know who cheek people are
that's a good one and and the fact that
you don't know who cheek people are is
your worst quality yeah yeah yeah go buy
some lips you reach around yeah
what okay you know what it doesn't now
you're on fire okay you started out I
mean good Lord yeah you didn't have it
it works yeah now it's fantastic yeah uh
no but Sona you are very good I've seen
Sona get mad many times
um and uh and often I have to say not at
me just at random people and uh you are
a terrific at swearing I am great
you are uh you are concise yes they
explode out of your face these these
curses is this the way you grew up no
because your parents would be horrified
that I'd be cursing they're nice that's
why I got good at it
that's why because my mom didn't want me
to to curse and so I was like well I'm
gonna show you I'm gonna curse the
person yeah yeah well good for you I'm
good thank you so much you overcame your
obstacles my dad no joke cursed a lot
and I'm wondering why that's why I'm bad
at cursing because I never got to
exercise that muscle I have a specific
memory which is uh my father you know
there wasn't much swearing in our house
occasionally our you know right there'd
be there wasn't there wasn't much
swearing at our house occasionally okay
that's nice wait I'm I'm being serious
cursing what are you talking about youth
Irish no the Irish curse means we have
small penises uh not that Irish makes
more sense yeah please that's the Irish
curse okay all right I mean I've been
looking for mine for years oh man I mean
give me a map
what were you gonna say uh no we're
gonna stick on this theme now I've used
ways to find it hey okay no we could we
could go somewhere else it's fine it's
solid C plus anyway uh you dropped your
penis it's at the bottom of that tequila
bottle
so anyway no no I grew up in a very
proper house my mother really didn't
want
um you know swearing and there wasn't a
lot of swearing really none at all and
then I'll never forget I had my uh my
room was up in the attic I lived up
there with my brother Neil and my sister
Kate
and we were there were so many of us
they they they they said okay some of
you were going up to the attic and it
was pretty clear who was headed up there
so I'm at the end of the attic now what
I remember you're saying you didn't draw
straws oh no no we didn't draw straws it
was you three U three up into the attic
now uh and we'll send a plate of food
and you can figure out who gets it there
was plenty of space a lot of empty
bedrooms tons of rooms boarding houses
we had a a we had a car on a revolving
display on the second floor that's so
much extra room we had 1975 Buick
Skylark there was just so much extra
room but anyway so I'm up there and I'm
in my bedroom and it's dark out and all
I remember is my father was coming up
and he was trying to uh he was trying to
find something and it was very late and
my sister Kate was not in her room at
the time and I think they were doing
some work in that room and all I know is
that there was a bunch of junk in there
including a big bed frame that was
jutting out at a weird angle and so I'm
in my bed and I'm just about to fall
asleep and my closet connected to my
sister's closet like you could walk from
one right through to the other so there
was yeah it was just a a way for my
sister to escape or for me to escape uh
it's the kind of house we lived in
anyway but I'm I'm not lying it they did
connect it was just an opening and you
could walk right into the other room and
so uh it's dark out and I'm just kind of
falling asleep and my father comes up
the stairs and he's looking for
something in Kate's room but it's dark
and all of a sudden I hear this
unmistakable sound of his shin hitting
the iron bed frame that's jutting out in
the darkness and I hurt
oh
every single swear you could ever
imagine oh you're censoring yourself but
he didn't well I like it's funnier to me
that it's just it's I remember it it was
so jarring and so traumatic I remember
it as
and I heard every swear that's ever been
invented from this like you know very
brilliant uh scientist he learned it all
in one film oh in one I mean if I had a
recorder running I'd have had them all
yeah it's like yep he got every single
one
and uh I remember just pulling the
pulling the blanket over my head oh my
god did you did he have like colloquial
swords because my dad for some reason
had his own like jazz swear lingo where
he would go God damn it anyway and God
damn it all make sure you damn it every
single way you can and all of it and he
would like but what is God damn it
anyway mean anyway God damn it just
completely takes the power away God damn
it anyway
he put up the Christmas tree and it
wouldn't work and God I love this man
and I love him for this but he'd be like
God damn it anyway God damn it all and
these were just like I don't know if
they were like passed down through the
family or what but I now will stub a toe
or something and like I have to stop
myself from going God damn it anyway I
think that's why I go to like you're a
cheek people yeah or a tooth lover I
don't know I just want to get away from
I want to stop the cycle we had a lot of
uh ethnic uh cursed words you know like
a lot of Turkish ones yeah my well one
of my oh this is bad for people who
actually know what I'm saying they're
bad but like one was like
or you know pezivinka shake things like
that those are the things my dad said
when he hit his shin he was Turkish my
dad's Turkish oh my God
one was all on your dad's soul and
my dad was saying that to people and
sometimes like you know he'd do it I'll
on your dad's soul that is
fantastic turkey
is like a like a pimp or 60 it is like
it or yeah you know
a son of a donkey you know it's yeah
it's it's not fine I mean whatever but
I'll on your dad's Soul yeah that
should they should win the Olympics yeah
graphic and poetic yeah it's like
figurative yeah it is also very gross
and I think of the show The Soul as
being ethereal like the would drop
through it but no this is proof that the
soul has some viscosity but what if the
only way you could materialize a soul is
to on it and you find like you know
when you pour paint on the Invisible Man
right if you on the soul you can
trap a soul right yeah check your toilet
bowl next time make sure there's
nobody's soul in there
oh no I just flushed grandma oh man well
she's going to a better place uh don't
on Grandma's Soul
she's going to a better place the water
salinization plants
Yeah in our house it was all Jesus Mary
and Joseph I mean it was all Catholic
yeah stuff and um and so it didn't
really it was just more of a prayer more
of a litany your grandma didn't swear oh
my God no my grandma Marty who lived
with us I didn't I don't know why didn't
I swear people are just they sweat they
swear no you're thinking of pirates no
you're
no my Irish grandmother was the most she
was a very well-educated school teacher
and she lived with us and she would say
oh Moses oh Moses that was the and she
would say it all the time like what's
wrong Maddie nothing
you just good night
bad news too she loved something
terrible happened oh tell me tell me and
she would love because the Irish love
bad news so once it was her birthday and
so I said hey Marty happy birthday and I
jumped off the top steps of our stairway
and pretended to get hurt because I
thought that would make her happy happy
birthday and I jumped and then I was
like did you like that he thought it was
hurt for a second oh Moses thank you
thank you well anyway this was a very
educational I think yeah Sona I will
never on your soul oh that's really
nice wait thinking no I won't oh okay
well we'll see how it goes today